"
>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
FOR THAT, WE GO TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
ANOTHER WEEK, ANOTHER ARTISTIC
TREASURE DEFILED BY CLIMATE
ACTIVISTS, I SEE.
>> LAURA, THIS TIME IT'S THE
NATIONAL GALLERY IN LONDON.
THE TARGET, VAN GOGH'S
SUNFLOWERS.
SOUP MIGHT BE GOOD FOOD BUT
ALWAYS A BAD PROTEST.
>> SECURITY!
>> WHAT IS WORTH MORE?
ART OR LIFE?
IS IT WORTH MORE THAN FOOD?
WORTH MORE THAN JUSTICE?
ARE YOU MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROTECTION OF A PAINTING OR THE
PROTECTION OF OUR PLANET AND
PEOPLE?
>> LAURA, HOW DO YOU CLAIM TO
PROTECT AND VALUE NATURE WHEN
ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
DEPICTIONS OF NATURE, VAN GOGH'S
SUN FLAW FLOWERS, YOU THROW SOUP
ON.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TO TAPE
THEMSELVES TO THE DUMPSTER AT AN
EMBLEM OF WHATNOT TO DO.
THIS IS A DISGRACE.
PROTEST ALL YOU WANT.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DEFILE
INTERNATIONAL TREASURES.
I'M SORRY.
>> Laura: LET'S BE VERY BLUNT.
THESE ARE CRIMINALS.
THEY SHOULD BE TREATED AS SUCH.
ALSO SPOILED BRATS THAT THINK
THAT THIS IS THEIR MOMENT.
IF THERE WEREN'T CAMERAS AROUND,
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT.
THIS IS TIK TOK MEETS THE CRIME
SYNDICATE FAMILY.
THIS TIME IT'S GOING AFTER ART.
>> THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO WARM
THAT SOUP SOON.
EVERYTHING WILL DRY UP ON THEM.
THE LAST THING THEY SHOULD BE
DOING IS NO EXPLORATION AND NO
FURTHER DRILLING, THIS IS
ABSURD.
YOU'LL BE WARMING YOURSELF I
DON'T KNOW WHEREBY THE SUN.
MAYBE THE SUNFLOWER.
AS INFLATION SPIKES AND OIL
DRIES UP HERE AT HOME AND COPS
ARE BEING GUNNED DOWN IN OUR
CITIES, THE PRESIDENT, I WANT
YOU TO KNOW, HE'S HARD AT WORK,
DOING THE IMPORTANT STUFF,
LAURA.
HE'S SILL BRACELETING JOY
BEHAR'S 80th BIRTHDAY.
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY, JOY.
>> NOBODY IS BETTER THAN YOU.
>> YOU SPEAK YOUR MIND, SPEAK
YOUR HEART.
YOU DO IT WITH WARMTH AND HUMOR.
>> WHAT?
>> MAYBE HE WAS WATCHING ANOTHER
HOST, LAURA.
>> EXCUSE ME, PLEASE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT --
>> I'M NOT INTERESTED IN YOUR --
>> I DON'T CARE WHAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN.
I'M TALKING.
>> I DON'T CARE --
>> WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> YOU MISS FIGHTING WITH ME --
>> I DID NOT MISS YOU.
>> SOMEBODY ANSWER THE QUESTION.
>> EVER SINCE BARBARA WALTERS
LEFT THAT SHOW, THE CHEMISTRY
HAS BEEN OFF BECAUSE NOBODY
COULD REIGN JOY BEHAR IN.
SHE WAS A FUNNY PET ON THE SIDE.
NOW SHE'S TURNED INTO A PARTISAN
ATTACK DOG.
THAT'S ALL SHE DOES EVERY DAY.
FOR JOE BIDEN TO CALL THAT WARM
AND HUMOROUS, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: RAYMOND, THE FUNNY
THING IS THAT WAS IN A
TELEPROMPTER.
HE COULDN'T COME UP WITH THAT.
HE ACTUALLY HAD TO HAVE THAT IN
PROMPTER.
>> IT BEGS A QUESTION, WHY IS
THE PRESIDENT DOING THESE
LITTLE -- IS HE ON CAMEO WHERE
YOU CAN ORDER HIM UP AND SEND A
VIDEO MESSAGE?
HOW DOES HE HAVE TIME TO DO A
TWO-CAMERA SHOOT WITH THE FIRST
LADY TO BE SENT TO JOY BEHAR
WHEN THE WORLD IS EXPLODING AND
INFLATION IS THROUGH THE ROOF?
>> Laura: LAST WEEK HE HAD TIME
TO TALK A TWO-HOUR TOUR OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA WITH
HIS GRANDDAUGHTER.
>> Laura: NOTHING ELSE TO DO.
NO.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU HAVE THE
BIDEN CENTER THERE FOR
INTERNATIONAL AND DIPLOMATIC
OUTREACH, I THINK THEY TEACH
WHATNOT TO DO ON THE
INTERNATIONAL SCENE THERE.
FINALLY, THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, WHICH REMEMBER, IT'S
ABOUT GETTING TO THE ROOTS OF
THE VIOLENCE THAT SWAMPED THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
THEY'RE SO EXCISED ABOUT
VIOLENCE THAT THEY SPENT
MILLIONS INVESTIGATE
ING TH
RIOT.
THE OTHER DAY THEY AIRED THIS
FOOTAGE FROM THE DOCUMENTARY
FILM MAKER, ALP LISANDRO PELOSI.
IT SHOWS PEACEFUL PELOSI ON
JANUARY 6.
>> I WANT TO PUNCH HIM OUT.
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS.
FOR TRESPASSING ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS.
I WANT TO PUNCH HIM OUT AND I'LL
GO TO JAIL AND I'LL BE HAPPY.
>> I WANT TO PUNCH THE PRESIDENT
OUT.
IMAGINE IF ANY OTHER HIGH-RANKED
DIGNITARY OFFICER OF THE OF THE
GO SAID THIS?
PELOSI IS TALKING ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BALANCE.
YOU CAN'T THREATEN WITH VIOLENCE
AND GO TO VIOLENCE EVERY TIME
PEOPLE DISAGREE WITH YOU?
>> YES, THEY CAN.
THEY CAN SAY WHEN TRUMP MAKES AN
OFF-HAND REMARK AT A RALLY ABOUT
SOMEONE GETTING PUNCHED BY
SOMEONE ELSE, THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE SAYING
SHE WANTS TO PHYSICALLY PUNCH
SOMEONE AS SHE CLAIMS VIOLENCE
IS AT A FEVER PITCH BECAUSE OF
REPUBLICANS.
REALLY, SWEETHEART?
>> MRS. PELOSI JANUARY 6 AND IT
COULD ALMOST BE A COMMENTARY ON
I'M GOING TO PUNCH HIM OUT
ROUTINE.
>> IT SHOWS THE WEAKNESS OF
THOSE THAT HAD TO SHOW THROUGH
VIOLENCE WHAT THEIR MESSAGE WAS.
>> YOU CAN SAY THAT AGAIN.
THIS IS A NARRATIVE, LAURA.
SHE'S TRYING TO BLAME SHIFT AND
CLAIM THE PRESIDENT IS THE
FOMENTER OF VIOLENCE.
THE FIRST INSTINCT IN PRIVATE IS
I WANT TO PUNCH HIM OUT.
I WANT TO GET HIM.
I'LL GO TO JAIL FOR IT.
THAT'S A PRE